- Willkommen zurück bei „Understanding Quantum Information and Computation".
Mein Name ist John Watrous und ich bin Technical Director für
Education bei IBM Quantum.
Dies ist die siebte Lektion der Reihe, und in dieser Lektion besprechen wir das Phasenschätzungsproblem und wie wir es
mit einem Quantencomputer lösen können.
Anschließend wenden wir die Phasenschätzung auf das Problem der ganzzahligen Faktorisierung an, das wir in der vorherigen Lektion besprochen haben.
Was wir dabei erhalten, ist Shor's Algorithmus, der es ermöglicht, ganze Zahlen
mit polynomialem Aufwand zu faktorisieren – oder in polynomialer Zeit, wenn wir lieber
in Begriffen der benötigten Zeit denken, anstatt in der Anzahl der
elementaren Operationen, die wir brauchen.
Dies ist gewissermaßen das Kronjuwel der
Quantenalgorithmen, und obwohl das Faktorisieren großer ganzer Zahlen
für die meisten Menschen von begrenztem Nutzen sein mag, bleibt es eines der überzeugendsten
Belege, die wir für die Hypothese haben, dass Quantencomputer
beeindruckende Vorteile bieten werden
gegenüber klassischen Computern. Hier ist ein Überblick über die Lektion.
Wir beginnen mit einer Definition des Phasenschätzungsproblems selbst, und dann besprechen wir eine Methode zur Lösung dieses Problems
mit einem Quantencomputer.
Wir gehen dabei Schritt für Schritt vor und beginnen mit dem, was du dir
als eine Art Aufwärmübung vorstellen kannst.
Beim Phasenschätzungsproblem besteht das Ziel darin, eine
bestimmte reelle Zahl zu approximieren, und in diesem Aufwärmteil
werden wir sehen, wie wir
eine sehr niedrig auflösende
Näherung dieser Zahl erhalten können.
Das wird für die Faktorisierung nicht
ausreichen, wenn wir unsere Lösung des
Phasenschätzungsproblems auf die ganzzahlige Faktorisierung anwenden,
denn wir werden tatsächlich eine ziemlich hochpräzise Näherung brauchen. Trotzdem ist es nützlich, mit einer solchen Aufwärmübung zu beginnen,
um ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen,
wie das Ganze funktioniert.
Anschließend besprechen wir die Frage, wie wir mehr Präzision erzielen können, was sehr
natürlich zu einer Operation führt, die als Quanten-Fourier-Transformation bekannt ist.
Wir werden genau sehen, was diese Operation ist und wie sie mit einem
quantum circuit implementiert werden kann.
Und sobald wir sie haben, werden wir sie auf die Phasenschätzung anwenden können,
um ein allgemeines Verfahren zur Lösung des Problems
mit sehr hoher Präzision zu entwickeln.
Im letzten Teil der Lektion werden wir dann sehen, wie eine Lösung des
Phasenschätzungsproblems es uns ermöglicht, ganze Zahlen effizient zu faktorisieren.
Und konkret werden wir Shor's Algorithmus zur
ganzzahligen Faktorisierung erhalten – oder zumindest etwas, das Shor's Algorithmus äquivalent ist.
Die Funktionsweise beruht im Wesentlichen darauf, dass wir uns
einen Zwischenschritt schaffen, nämlich ein weiteres Problem, das als Ordnungsfindungsproblem bezeichnet wird.
Insbesondere werden wir sehen, wie wir das Ordnungsfindungsproblem mithilfe des Phasenschätzungsverfahrens lösen können, und dann werden wir sehen, wie wir ganze Zahlen faktorisieren können,
indem wir das Ordnungsfindungsproblem lösen. Wir beginnen mit einem Spezialfall eines Satzes namens Spektralsatz,
und insbesondere werden wir uns darauf konzentrieren, was uns der Satz
für unitäre Matrizen sagt.
Der Spektralsatz ist
ein sehr wichtiger Satz aus der linearen Algebra und
der Funktionalanalysis.
Er sagt uns etwas Interessantes darüber, wie bestimmte lineare Abbildungen in einer bestimmten Form ausgedrückt werden können – diese wird oft als
Spektralzerlegung bezeichnet,
was aus vielen Gründen nützlich ist.
Und wie gesagt, werden wir uns darauf konzentrieren, was dieser Satz
uns für unitäre Matrizen sagt.
Der Spektralsatz ist
allgemeiner als das. Er gilt nicht für alle Matrizen, aber er gilt für eine Klasse von Matrizen,
die als normale Matrizen bezeichnet werden, zu denen alle unitären Matrizen sowie einige Matrizen
gehören, die nicht unitär sind.
Aber um die Dinge einfach zu halten, beschränken wir unsere Aufmerksamkeit
vorerst auf unitäre Matrizen, da das alles ist, was wir für
die Zwecke dieser Lektion benötigen.
Hier ist eine Formulierung des Spektralsatzes nur für unitäre Matrizen.
Angenommen, U ist eine
N mal N unitäre Matrix.
Was der Satz besagt,
ist, dass es eine Orthonormalbasis von
Vektoren, Psi eins bis Psi N, geben muss,
zusammen mit N komplexen Zahlen
Lambda eins bis Lambda N, die alle auf dem komplexen Einheitskreis liegen, sodass U durch die Gleichung ausgedrückt werden kann, die wir hier haben.
Dies wird, wie ich bereits erwähnt habe, als Spektralzerlegung
von U bezeichnet, und es kann sehr praktisch sein zu wissen, dass U auf diese Weise geschrieben werden kann.
Es kann manchmal nützlich sein, diese Vektoren und diese Zahlen zur Hand zu haben, wenn wir mit
einer bestimmten unitären Matrix U arbeiten, und es kann auch sehr
nützlich sein, einfach zu wissen,
dass ein solcher Ausdruck immer möglich ist – etwa als Möglichkeit, bestimmte Eigenschaften unitärer Matrizen zu beweisen.
In dieser Formulierung des Satzes ist jede dieser Zahlen,
Lambda eins bis Lambda N, auf eine bestimmte Weise geschrieben,
nämlich als E hoch zwei Pi I mal Theta, wobei jedes der Thetas
Theta eins bis Theta N eine reelle Zahl ist, und
wir werden gleich auf diese Art,
jede dieser Zahlen zu schreiben,
zurückkommen.
Ein wichtiger Aspekt dieser Vektoren und Zahlen ist, dass jeder Vektor Psi
K ein Eigenvektor der Matrix U sein muss mit
dem zugehörigen Eigenwert Lambda K.
Das bedeutet, dass wenn wir
Psi K mit U multiplizieren, wir Lambda K mal Psi K erhalten.
Was U also mit jedem dieser Vektoren macht, ist einfach, ihn mit der entsprechenden Zahl Lambda K zu multiplizieren.
Im Allgemeinen wird U bei einem beliebigen Vektor nicht so funktionieren, aber Eigenvektoren sind besonders.
Und was uns der Satz sagt, ist, dass es tatsächlich
eine Orthonormalbasis aus diesen Eigenvektoren gibt.
Diese Gleichung hier unten ergibt sich übrigens aus dem Ausdruck für U aus dem Satz, zusammen mit der Tatsache, dass
die Vektoren orthonormal sind.
Wenn du den
Ausdruck von U auf beliebiges Psi K anwendest und die Orthonormalität der Vektoren verwendest, erhältst du eine Summe, in der
alle Terme null sind
außer einem davon, und der eine Term, mit dem wir
übrig bleiben, sieht so aus.
Jetzt können wir das
Phasenschätzungsproblem definieren.
Das Problem ist, wie wir sehen werden,
ein wenig ungewöhnlich.
Uns werden zwei Dinge gegeben. Erstens bekommen wir die Beschreibung eines unitären Quanten-circuit,
der auf N qubits wirkt,
für eine beliebige Wahl von N, und wenn wir sagen, dass dieser
ein unitärer circuit ist,
meinen wir damit nur, dass alle
gates unitär sind, es also keine Messungen
in diesem circuit gibt.
Zweitens erhalten wir einen N-qubit-Zustand Psi, und das ist der ungewöhnliche Teil.
Wir haben tatsächlich einen Quantenzustand
als Eingabe für dieses Problem,
und es ist eine einzige Kopie dieses Zustands.
Bei allen anderen Rechenproblemen, die wir in dieser Reihe besprochen haben, war die Eingabe klassisch, entweder in Form einer Bitfolge
oder als Black Box.
Das ist nicht überraschend, denn die Rechenprobleme,
die uns im Alltag begegnen, sind in der Regel klassisch,
weil das die
Probleme sind, um die wir uns am meisten kümmern.
Die Art, wie du dieses Problem
betrachten kannst, ist, dass es etwas ist, das als Teilproblem auftritt oder wahrscheinlich auftreten wird.
Und das Phasenschätzungsverfahren, das wir schließlich entwickeln werden, ist etwas, das wir
in der Regel als Unterroutine verwenden
innerhalb einer größeren Berechnung, vermutlich einer für ein klassisches
Problem, das uns interessiert.
Dies wird nun ein Promise-Problem sein, und der Zustand Psi ist nicht
irgendein beliebiger Quantenzustand.
Uns wird versprochen, dass Psi ein Eigenvektor der unitären Operation U ist, die der gegebene circuit beschreibt.
Und das Ziel ist es, den Eigenwert, der dem Eigenvektor Psi entspricht,
zu finden oder anzunähern.
Lass uns das Problem
etwas präziser formulieren.
Die Eingabe besteht aus einem unitären
Quanten-circuit auf N qubits, der als Bitfolge kodiert werden kann
nach welcher Methode wir auch immer bevorzugen, um Quanten-circuit-Beschreibungen zu kodieren, zusammen mit einem N-qubit-Zustand Psi.
Wir können den circuit benennen, wie wir möchten, aber was im Hinblick auf die Formulierung dieses Problems wirklich wichtig ist, ist die unitäre Operation selbst,
die ausgeführt wird, wenn der circuit läuft, und diese unitäre Operation
wird durch die Matrix U beschrieben.
Aber U wird uns nicht als Matrix gegeben, wir erhalten lediglich die Beschreibung eines Quanten-circuit, der U implementiert.
Das Versprechen, wie ich bereits erwähnt habe, ist, dass Psi ein Eigenvektor von U ist.
Wenn wir also unseren circuit auf Psi anwenden würden, bekämen wir Psi heraus, multipliziert mit dem jeweiligen Eigenwert,
was in diesem Fall eine
globale Phase wäre.
Und schließlich ist die Ausgabe des Problems eine Näherung des Eigenwerts, der Psi entspricht, und konkret suchen wir nach
einer Näherung der reellen Zahl Theta, zwischen null und eins, einschließlich
null, aber nicht einschließlich eins,
die die Gleichung erfüllt,
die wir auf dem Bildschirm sehen.
Um diese Art der
Parametrisierung des zu Psi gehörenden Eigenwerts zu erläutern, und auch um zu klären, was wir unter einer Näherung verstehen,
lass uns ein Bild des
komplexen Einheitskreises zeichnen.
Wir können die Zahlen eins, I,
minus eins und minus I an ihre üblichen Stellen setzen und können betrachten,
einen beliebigen Punkt auf dem
Kreis, parametrisiert durch Theta, wie wir es in der Problemformulierung haben.
Das ist der Punkt, den wir
erhalten, wenn wir bei eins beginnen und um einen Winkel von
zwei mal Pi mal Theta drehen, der Winkel ist also nicht
Theta, sondern zwei Pi Theta,
und eine andere Art, darüber nachzudenken, ist, dass wenn wir bei eins starten und eine Strecke von zwei Pi Theta auf dem Kreis zurücklegen,
wir zu unserem Punkt E hoch
zwei mal Pi mal Theta gelangen.
Jeder Punkt des komplexen Einheitskreises kann auf diese Weise
für eine eindeutige Wahl von Theta dargestellt werden.
Das liegt daran, dass wir
einmal den gesamten Kreis umrunden, wenn Theta von null bis eins geht, und wenn wir bis
Theta gleich eins gehen würden,
wären wir wieder dort, wo wir
bei Theta gleich null angefangen haben, deshalb schließen wir null ein, aber nicht eins.
Nur um sicherzustellen, dass jeder
Punkt auf dem komplexen Einheitskreis einem eindeutigen Wert von Theta im betrachteten Bereich entspricht.
Es gibt verschiedene Möglichkeiten,
wie wir uns vorstellen könnten, einen bestimmten Wert von Theta anzunähern, aber die Art, wie wir es tun, ist, Theta mit einem Bruch anzunähern,
wobei der Nenner
zwei hoch M ist, für eine beliebige Wahl einer positiven ganzen Zahl M, und der Zähler eine ganze Zahl y ist
zwischen null und zwei hoch M minus eins.
Du kannst dir das als eine M-bit-Näherung von Theta vorstellen, wenn du möchtest, und wir könnten diese
Zahl in binärer Notation schreiben
wo wir einen Binärpunkt haben, gefolgt von der binären
Darstellung von Y.
Ich sage übrigens Binärpunkt
statt Dezimalpunkt, weil Dezimal Basis 10 bedeutet und ich hier über Basis zwei
spreche, aber es ist dasselbe Konzept.
Aber wie dem auch sei, wir können
es auch einfach als einen Bruch betrachten, wie er
auf dem Bildschirm erscheint.
Und um das klarzustellen: wenn wir über
Näherungen in diesem Kontext nachdenken, sollte verstanden werden,
dass Werte von Theta
nahe null und Werte von Theta nahe eins tatsächlich nahe beieinander liegen.
Wenn zum Beispiel Theta gleich 0,99 ist und wir diesen Wert
von Theta durch den Wert null annähern,
dann ist das eine ziemlich gute Näherung in dem Sinne, dass sie
innerhalb von einem Hundertstel des tatsächlichen Wertes liegt, wenn
wir um den Kreis herumgehen
und bei null wieder anfangen, sobald wir bei eins angelangt sind.
Der Begriff „modular eins" wird manchmal verwendet, um die Situation zu beschreiben, in der wir
theta gleich eins mit theta gleich null gleichsetzen.
Der Punkt ist, dass es uns wirklich auf die Position des Punktes
E hoch zwei pi I theta auf dem Einheitskreis ankommt,
und diese Art, theta zu approximieren, ergibt Sinn,
wenn wir dieses Ziel vor Augen haben.
Die Problemstellung selbst,
wie sie auf dem Bildschirm erscheint, macht keine genauen Angaben darüber, wie gut die Näherung für theta sein muss,
aber das ist etwas, das wir je nach unseren Bedürfnissen fein abstimmen können.
In manchen Situationen sind wir vielleicht mit einer Näherung
geringer Genauigkeit für theta zufrieden, und in anderen Situationen fordern wir vielleicht
eine sehr hochpräzise Näherung, und die Problemstellung selbst
kann entsprechend verfeinert werden.
Als Nächstes werden wir sehen, wie wir das
Phasenschätzungsproblem mit einem Quantencomputer lösen können, und
wir beginnen mit einer Aufwärmübung.
Das wird nicht unsere endgültige
Lösung des Problems sein.
Was wir tun werden, ist das Phase-Kickback-Phänomen zu nutzen, um etwas über
den Eigenwert zu erfahren, der einem bestimmten Eigenvektor entspricht.
Zur Erinnerung: Beim
Phasenschätzungsproblem erhalten wir die Beschreibung
eines unitären quantum circuit für eine Operation U,
und was wir zuerst tun, ist diese circuit-Beschreibung zu verwenden,
um einen neuen circuit zu erstellen, der eine gesteuerte U-Operation implementiert, wie
sie auf dem Bildschirm abgebildet ist.
Das ist ziemlich einfach zu machen. Was wir tun können, ist ein Steuer-qubit hinzuzufügen, das in
diesem Diagramm oben abgebildet ist,
und dieses neue Steuer-qubit als Steuerung für jeden einzelnen gate zu verwenden, der
in unserem circuit vorkommt.
Alle gates werden also angewendet, wenn dieses Steuer-qubit auf eins gesetzt ist, und keiner von ihnen wird angewendet, wenn das Steuer-qubit auf null gesetzt ist.
Das bedeutet, dass wir
eine gesteuerte Version von jedem gate benötigen, der
im circuit U vorkommt, aber wir müssen diese neuen gesteuerten gates
nicht als einzelne gates betrachten,
wenn wir das nicht wollen. Sie könnten als kleine circuits implementiert werden,
die aus gates aus welchem gate-Set auch immer bestehen,
das wir zu verwenden gewählt haben. Und sobald wir eine
gesteuerte Version von U haben, können wir in Betracht ziehen, diesen circuit auszuführen,
bei dem wir zunächst das Steuer-qubit in eine Superposition aus null und eins bringen, den gesteuerten U-gate auf die Eigenvektor-Seite anwenden, die uns gegeben wird,
und dann einen Hadamard gate
auf die Steuerung anwenden und messen.
Wir werden sehen, warum es sinnvoll ist, das so zu machen, wenn wir die Analyse durchgehen, aber schon bevor wir zu den Details kommen, können wir sofort eine Ähnlichkeit erkennen
mit Deutschs Algorithmus zum Beispiel, bei dem wir
ein paar Hadamard gates anwenden und messen, um
effektiv zu erkunden,
was eine bestimmte gegebene
Operation hier macht.
Es handelt sich um eine gesteuerte unitäre Operation
anstelle eines Abfrage-gates, aber es sind sehr ähnliche Ideen im Spiel.
Schauen wir uns also an, was der circuit macht.
Der Anfangszustand ist der Eigenvektor psi, tensoriert mit dem Null-
Zustand für das Steuer-qubit,
die Anwendung des ersten Hadamard gates transformiert den Zustand des
oberen qubit in einen Plus-Zustand, und wir können den gesamten
Zustand so entwickeln, wie es hier gezeigt wird.
Dann wenden wir die gesteuerte U-Operation an, und das bewirkt, dass U auf psi angewendet wird, wenn das Steuer-qubit auf eins gesetzt ist,
aber nicht wenn es auf null gesetzt ist. So erhalten wir den Zustand pi zwei,
der auf dem Bildschirm geschrieben steht.
Wir können den Zustand vereinfachen,
indem wir die Tatsache nutzen, dass psi ein Eigenvektor von U mit dem Eigenwert e hoch zwei pi I theta ist.
Wir erhalten also diesen Eigenwert, der den zweiten
Term multipliziert, aber nicht den ersten.
Und wir können mithilfe der Bilinearität
des Tensorprodukts vereinfachen.
Was wir hier also haben, ist das Phase-Kickback-Phänomen, aber diesmal geschieht es für einen beliebigen Eigenvektor psi einer beliebigen unitären Operation U,
im Gegensatz zu einer Not-Operation, die auf einen Minus-
Zustand angewendet wird, um genauer zu sein.
Das ist also der Zustand, nachdem die gesteuerte U-Operation angewendet wurde.
Übrigens lohnt es sich,
einen Moment innezuhalten und zu bemerken, dass der Zustand der unteren n qubits immer noch der Eigenvektor psi ist.
Was großartig ist, denn das
gibt uns die Möglichkeit, ihn erneut zu verwenden, wenn wir das möchten.
Dann wird der zweite Hadamard gate ausgeführt, und hier ist der Zustand, den wir erhalten.
Ich habe hier nicht alle
Details der Herleitung gezeigt, aber wenn du den
Hadamard gate anwendest und vereinfachst, ist das, was du erhalten solltest.
Das ist also der Zustand direkt
vor der Messung.
Wir können uns auf diesen Zustand konzentrieren, um zu sehen, was wir durch Messen
über theta erfahren können.
Und wenn wir das obere
qubit oder das rechteste qubit messen, sind das die Wahrscheinlichkeiten, die wir für die beiden Ergebnisse erhalten.
Und hier wurden ein paar
grundlegende Formeln verwendet, die Sinus und Kosinus
zu komplexen Exponentialfunktionen in Beziehung setzen, um diese Wahrscheinlichkeiten auszudrücken,
in Termen von Sinus und Kosinus.
Konkret ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, null zu erhalten, der Kosinus zum Quadrat von pi mal theta, und die Wahrscheinlichkeit, eins zu erhalten,
ist der Sinus zum Quadrat desselben Winkels. Und das macht Sinn,
denn der Sinus zum Quadrat plus der Kosinus zum Quadrat eines
beliebigen Winkels ist gleich eins.
Unsere Wahrscheinlichkeiten
summieren sich also zu eins, wie wir es erwarten.
Und hier ist ein Diagramm dieser Wahrscheinlichkeiten als Funktion von Theta.
Um das klarzustellen: Dies ist ein Diagramm der
Wahrscheinlichkeiten selbst, im Gegensatz zu einem Diagramm, das eine einzelne Wahrscheinlichkeitsverteilung darstellt.
Wenn Theta zum Beispiel
gleich ein halb ist, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass wir das Ergebnis Eins erhalten, das in Lila dargestellt ist, gleich Eins.
Während die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
das Ergebnis Null zu erhalten, das in Blau dargestellt ist, gleich Null ist.
Wenn Theta hingegen gleich einem
Viertel oder drei Vierteln ist, dann ist jedes der beiden Ergebnisse gleich wahrscheinlich.
Und natürlich ist für alle Werte von Theta die Summe der Wahrscheinlichkeiten gleich Eins, wie wir bereits festgestellt haben.
Wir erfahren also nicht genau, was
Theta ist, durch dieses Verfahren, aber es gibt uns
einige Informationen über Theta.
Und wenn wir uns eine Situation vorstellen, in der uns
versichert wird, dass Theta gleich Null oder Theta gleich ein halb ist, dann wird uns dieses Verfahren sagen,
welche der beiden Möglichkeiten
es genau ist.
Das ist also eine einfache Möglichkeit, das Phase-Kickback-Phänomen zu nutzen, um etwas über den Eigenwert zu lernen.
Wie können wir also mehr
über den Eigenwert erfahren?
Nun, das ist eine Situation, in der wir
die Unwissenheit als Leitfaden nutzen können.
Denn es gibt wirklich nicht
allzu viele Dinge, die wir tun können.
Wir wissen so gut wie nichts
über den Eigenvektor psi, und wir wissen auch nicht
viel über die Operation U.
Wir haben einen circuit für U, aber soweit wir wissen, ist er
ein schreckliches, verwirrendes Durcheinander, das wir durch
Untersuchen nicht verstehen können.
Aber eine naheliegende Option ist, den circuit mehrmals auszuführen.
Insbesondere könnten wir versuchen, genau dasselbe zu tun, was wir gerade getan haben, nur dass wir statt einer einzelnen kontrollierten U-Operation
diese Operation zweimal anwenden. Oder wir könnten sie beliebig oft anwenden, aber fangen wir mit zweimal an,
um zu sehen, was passiert.
Nun, was passiert ist eigentlich recht
einfach. Indem wir die kontrollierte
U-Operation zweimal anwenden, quadrieren wir effektiv nur
den Eigenwert,
weil er zwei Mal statt nur einmal in die
Phase des oberen qubit eingebracht wird.
Und wenn wir also über
die Ergebniswahrscheinlichkeiten als Funktion von Theta nachdenken, verdoppeln wir im Wesentlichen nur
die Frequenz.
Für jede mögliche Wahl von Theta sind die Ergebniswahrscheinlichkeiten
dieselben, wie sie wären, wenn wir Theta verdoppelt und dann
den gebrochenen Anteil genommen hätten,
um eine Zahl zwischen Null und Eins zu erhalten.
Wenn Theta zum Beispiel
gleich ein halb ist, dann ist der Eigenwert minus Eins.
Indem wir U zweimal anwenden, quadrieren wir also effektiv den Eigenwert, und das Ergebnis ist dasselbe, wie es für Theta gleich Null wäre.
Das bedeutet, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit
für das Ergebnis Null, in Blau dargestellt, gleich Eins ist, und die Wahrscheinlichkeit für das Ergebnis Eins, in Lila dargestellt, gleich Null ist.
Das ist sehr einfach, aber wir können tatsächlich
einige zusätzliche Informationen über Theta gewinnen, indem wir das tun.
Wenn wir zum Beispiel im Voraus wissen, dass Theta entweder gleich Null oder gleich ein Viertel ist, dann wird uns dieser circuit verraten,
welche der beiden Möglichkeiten es ist.
Andererseits können wir den Fall, dass Theta gleich Null ist, nicht mehr von dem Fall unterscheiden, dass Theta gleich ein halb ist.
Dieses Verfahren ist also nicht unbedingt besser als das vorherige, bei dem
wir ein einzelnes kontrolliertes U gate hatten, aber indem wir auch diesen circuit ausführen,
können wir zusätzliche Informationen gewinnen.
Es ist nicht unmittelbar klar,
wie die zusätzlichen Informationen, die wir durch die mehrfache Iteration der kontrollierten U-Operation gewinnen können,
mit den Informationen in Einklang gebracht werden können,
die wir durch eine einmalige Ausführung erhalten, und tatsächlich gibt es mehrere
Möglichkeiten, wie wir vorgehen könnten.
Es gibt zum Beispiel eine Technik namens iterative Phasenschätzung, bei der circuits wie die, die wir gesehen haben, ausgeführt werden,
zusammen mit einigen kleineren Variationen davon, um eine Näherung für Theta zu erhalten.
Aber ich werde
einen eher traditionellen Ansatz beschreiben, bei dem wir einen einzigen Quanten-circuit verwenden, der mehrere Steuer-qubits hat,
die verschiedene
Anzahlen von Iterationen der unitären Operation U steuern.
Zunächst beschreibe ich, wie das
für zwei Steuer-qubits funktioniert, und etwas später verallgemeinern wir das auf mehr als zwei Steuer-qubits.
Hier ist ein Quanten-circuit,
der zwei Steuer-qubits verwendet.
Das obere Steuer-qubit
steuert eine einzelne U-Operation, während das zweite von oben
qubit zwei Kopien von U steuert.
Was wir also tun, ist, die beiden circuits, die wir zuvor gesehen haben, zu kombinieren, so dass wir die einzelne Kopie
des Eigenvektors psi verwenden, die wir haben.
Du wirst jedoch bemerken,
dass die Hadamard gates nach den kontrollierten U-Operationen
entfernt wurden und es noch keine Messungen gibt.
Was wir tun werden, ist zu
sehen, wie dieser circuit funktioniert, und dann herausfinden,
was wir mit den beiden oberen qubits tun sollten,
um so viel wie möglich über den Wert Theta zu erfahren, den
wir zu approximieren versuchen.
Nach den ausgeführten Hadamard gates hatten wir den Zustand, der
auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt wird.
Und das ist eine praktische Möglichkeit, den Zustand zu schreiben, um
zu sehen, was als nächstes passiert.
A Null und A Eins sind Bits, und wenn wir die beiden oberen qubits als ein Zwei-qubit-Register betrachten,
denken wir an A Null, das dem oberen qubit entspricht, als das weniger signifikante Bit, und A Eins, das dem
unteren Steuer-qubit entspricht,
als das höherwertige Bit.
Nach der ersten kontrollierten
U-Operation erhalten wir diesen Zustand.
Der klassische Zustand des oberen Kontroll-qubit ist null, also kann das Ergebnis des Phase-Kickbacks
auf diese Weise ausgedrückt werden. Dann nach der zweiten und
dritten kontrollierten U-Operation
erhalten wir diesen Zustand.
Die Idee ist dieselbe wie bei der ersten, nur wenden wir diesmal die kontrollierte U-Operation zweimal an.
Daher multiplizieren wir A eins mit zwei im
Exponenten, um das widerzuspiegeln.
Und jetzt können wir diesen Ausdruck vereinfachen, indem wir die Bits
A eins und A null zusammen als eine ganze Zahl zwischen null und
drei in binärer Notation betrachten.
Das heißt, wenn wir den
zweistelligen Bit-String A eins A null als binäre
Kodierung einer ganzen Zahl betrachten,
erhalten wir zwei
mal A eins plus A null.
Dabei ist zu verstehen,
dass wenn wir Cat X schreiben, wir von X als binärem String der Länge
zwei in binärer Notation sprechen.
Konzentrieren wir uns jetzt auf
diese zwei Kontroll-qubits, um herauszufinden, was wir
an diesem Punkt über Theta lernen können.
Die verbleibenden N qubits befinden sich
noch immer im selben Zustand Psi, den wir ursprünglich erhalten haben, was wirklich ein wunderbarer
Aspekt dieses Ansatzes ist
denn wie ich vorhin sagte, können wir diesen Zustand erneut verwenden, wenn wir noch mehr
Informationen über Theta gewinnen möchten.
Aber für jetzt denken wir einfach darüber nach, was wir von
diesen zwei Kontroll-qubits lernen können.
Um herauszufinden, wie wir vorgehen sollen, stellen wir uns vor, dass uns versprochen wird, dass Theta gleich Y durch vier ist
für eine ganze Zahl Y zwischen null und drei.
Im Allgemeinen muss Theta nicht
einer dieser vier Werte sein, aber das ist ein naheliegender Fall, den man betrachten sollte.
Wir haben in der ursprünglichen Version mit einem einzigen Kontroll-qubit gesehen, dass wenn uns versprochen wird, dass Theta entweder null oder ein halb ist,
der circuit verrät, welches der Fall ist. Wir haben auch festgestellt, dass in der Version, bei der wir die
kontrollierte U-Operation zweimal angewendet haben,
wir den Fall Theta gleich null vom Fall Theta
gleich einem Viertel perfekt unterscheiden konnten.
Daher könnten wir hoffen, dass wir mit unserem neuen circuit diese vier Fälle unterscheiden können.
Im Wesentlichen nutzen wir
dabei das Konzept eines Promise-Problems,
um das Problem zu vereinfachen, sodass wir sehen können, wie wir vorgehen sollen.
Und das ist keine schlechte Idee im Allgemeinen. Wenn du ein Problem hast und
nicht weißt, wie du es lösen sollst, versuche es einfacher zu machen.
Wenn du das einfachere Problem lösen kannst, könnte dir die gewonnene Erkenntnis helfen, das allgemeinere Problem zu lösen.
Und wenn du das einfachere Problem nicht lösen kannst, bist du wahrscheinlich noch nicht bereit
für das allgemeinere Problem.
Also mach es immer einfacher,
bis du es lösen kannst.
Kommen wir jedenfalls zu unserem Problem zurück und definieren wir für jeden möglichen Wert von Y einen Zwei-qubit-Zustand.
Mit anderen Worten ist Phi Y gleich dem Zustand,
der oben auf dem Bildschirm angezeigt wird, wenn Theta speziell
als Y durch vier gewählt wird.
Und hier sind diese vier
Zustände explizit aufgeschrieben.
Zur Wiederholung: Wenn
Theta gleich Y durch vier ist, wobei Y null, eins, zwei oder
drei ist, und wir unseren circuit ausführen,
erhalten wir
einen dieser vier Zustände, nämlich denjenigen, der
dem richtigen Wert von Y entspricht.
Und wir möchten einfach herausfinden,
welcher es ist.
Und die Frage ist: Ist das möglich?
Und die Antwort auf diese Frage ist ja, denn diese vier Zustände sind orthogonal.
Wenn du das innere Produkt
zwischen einem beliebigen Paar von ihnen berechnest, erhältst du null.
Und weil sie orthogonal sind, können sie durch eine projektive Messung perfekt unterschieden werden.
Und insbesondere können wir
eine solche Messung ausdrücken, indem wir eine Projektion für jeden Vektor definieren, wie wir hier sehen.
Das funktioniert immer,
wenn wir eine Orthonormalbasis haben, und du kannst das für diesen speziellen Fall
gegen die Definitionen aus Lektion drei prüfen,
wenn du dazu geneigt bist. Wir schließen also daraus, dass es
möglich ist, unsere Aufgabe zu erfüllen,
also den Wert von Y aus dem Zustand zu lernen, der oben
auf dem Bildschirm angezeigt wird.
Und wenn wir das
mit einem quantum circuit tun möchten, können wir wie folgt vorgehen, wie ich jetzt erklären werde.
Zunächst können wir eine unitäre Matrix V definieren, deren Spalten die vier
in der Reihenfolge aufgelisteten Vektoren sind.
Diese Matrix wird die am unteren Bildschirmrand beschriebene Wirkung
auf die Standardbasisvektoren haben,
und wir können die Matrix aufschreiben,
um zu sehen, wie sie aussieht.
Da V jeden Standardbasisvektor Kappa Y auf den Vektor Phi Y abbildet, haben wir, dass durch Anwenden von V Dagger,
oder mit anderen Worten V invers, auf Phi Y wir in die andere Richtung zum entsprechenden Standardbasisvektor zurücktransformieren.
Was wir also tun können, ist V Dagger auf den Zustand anzuwenden, den wir
von unserem circuit erhalten haben.
Und wenn wir dann eine
Standardbasismessung durchführen, erhalten wir die Zahl Y,
nach der wir suchen, ausgedrückt als
String der Länge zwei in binärer Form.
Bevor wir weitermachen, lass uns noch etwas mehr
über die unitäre Matrix V sprechen.
Das ist eine besondere Matrix und
du hast sie vielleicht schon einmal gesehen.
Es ist die Matrix, die mit einer
linearen Operation auf vierdimensionalen Vektoren verbunden ist, bekannt als die diskrete Fourier-Transformation.
Genauer gesagt lässt sich die diskrete Fourier-Transformation für jede
positive ganzzahlige Dimension definieren, und wir werden sie
gleich in allgemeiner Form betrachten.
Und so sieht sie konkret aus,
wenn die Dimension gleich vier ist.
Wir können die
diskrete Fourier-Transformation auf verschiedene Weisen betrachten.
Wir können sie rein abstrakt als lineare Abbildung auf Vektoren betrachten, die durch eine Matrix dargestellt werden kann.
Und wir können sie auch als ein
Berechnungsproblem betrachten, bei dem uns ein Vektor gegeben ist und wir das Ergebnis berechnen möchten
der Anwendung dieser linearen Abbildung.
Das stellt sich als ein unglaublich wichtiges
Berechnungsproblem heraus, und es gibt einen hocheffizienten Algorithmus zur Durchführung dieser Berechnung
bekannt als die schnelle Fourier-Transformation.
Tatsächlich ist dies in der Signalverarbeitung zum Beispiel ein so wichtiges Problem, dass die schnelle Fourier-
Transformation von vielen
als einer der wichtigsten und folgenreichsten
jemals entdeckten Algorithmen angesehen wird.
Wir können die
diskrete Fourier-Transformation auch als eine unitäre Quantenoperation betrachten, die auf einen
Quantenzustandsvektor angewendet werden kann.
Und wenn wir sie auf diese Weise betrachten, nennen wir sie die Quanten-Fourier-
Transformation, oder kurz QFT.
Mathematisch gesehen ist sie im Wesentlichen dasselbe wie die diskrete Fourier-Transformation, aber wir nennen sie die
Quanten-Fourier-Transformation,
nur um klarzustellen, dass es sich um eine Operation handelt, die auf einen Quantenzustandsvektor angewendet wird.
Lass uns also den Namen unserer Matrix von V zu QFT vier ändern, um der Tatsache Rechnung zu tragen,
dass die Operation, auf die wir gekommen sind, tatsächlich die Quanten-Fourier-Transformation ist.
Hier ist also der vollständige circuit zum Ermitteln des Werts von Y, wenn uns versprochen wird, dass
theta gleich Y durch vier ist
für Y gleich null, eins, zwei oder drei.
Und nur um sicherzustellen, dass es klar ist: Wir wenden die Inverse der
Quanten-Fourier-Transformation an, also mit anderen Worten QFT vier Dagger,
um einen der vier möglichen Zustände auf den Standardbasiszustand, Ket Y, abzubilden, damit wir Y durch Messen ermitteln können.
Das ist also der circuit, den wir
erhalten, wenn wir über die versprochene Version des
Phasenschätzproblems nachdenken, bei der uns versprochen wird, dass theta
null, ein Viertel, ein
Halb oder drei Viertel ist, aber es gibt nichts, das uns daran hindert,
diesen circuit für
einen beliebigen Wert von theta auszuführen.
Und wenn wir das tun, sind hier
die Wahrscheinlichkeiten für die vier möglichen
Ergebnisse, die wir erhalten.
Jeder der vier möglichen
Werte für Y hat seine eigene Farbe, und der Plot zeigt uns,
wie hoch die Wahrscheinlichkeiten für jeden einzelnen als Funktion von theta sind.
Wenn theta zum Beispiel
gleich drei Viertel ist, erhalten wir das Ergebnis
drei mit Wahrscheinlichkeit eins,
wobei die Wahrscheinlichkeiten für die anderen drei Ergebnisse alle null sind, wie wir bereits aus der Betrachtung der versprochenen Version des Problems wissen.
Wenn theta nahe bei drei Viertel liegt, aber nicht genau drei Viertel ist, gibt es eine gewisse Wahrscheinlichkeit ungleich null für die anderen Ergebnisse,
aber wir erhalten das Ergebnis
drei trotzdem mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit.
Selbst wenn theta also möglicherweise
nicht gleich Y durch vier ist, können wir das Ergebnis, das wir aus den Messungen erhalten, geteilt durch vier,
als eine Schätzung oder eine
Annäherung an theta betrachten.
Die Schätzung kann falsch sein, aber dennoch
liefert sie uns Informationen.
Und eines, was wir
aus dem Plot lernen können, ist, dass die besten Annäherungen immer die höchsten
Wahrscheinlichkeiten haben, die ihnen zugeordnet sind.
Wenn ich von der besten Annäherung spreche, meine ich den Wert von Y durch vier, der dem wahren Wert von theta am nächsten liegt,
im modular-eins-Sinne. Der schlimmste mögliche Fall ist, dass theta genau in der Mitte zwischen
zwei Werten von Y durch vier liegt.
Wenn theta zum Beispiel gleich
drei Achtel oder 0,375 ist, sehen wir in diesem Fall,
dass die Annäherungen
ein Viertel und zwei Viertel
oder ein Halb gleich gut sind.
In diesem besonderen
Fall gibt es also tatsächlich zwei beste Annäherungen statt einer.
Und wir erhalten mit gleicher Wahrscheinlichkeit das Ergebnis eins
und das Ergebnis zwei.
Die anderen beiden Ergebnisse null und drei, die keine besonders guten
Annäherungen an theta liefern, wenn wir durch vier dividieren, erscheinen tatsächlich mit einer gewissen Wahrscheinlichkeit
die in beiden Fällen
knapp unter 10 % zu liegen scheint.
Dieses Verfahren ist also nicht perfekt, aber es liefert uns Informationen.
Und es ist bemerkenswert, dass
wir unabhängig von theta immer garantiert entweder die beste Annäherung
oder eine der beiden besten Annäherungen bei einem Gleichstand ziehen, mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit,
die knapp über 40 % zu liegen scheint.
Und je näher theta
an der Annäherung liegt, desto höher ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, den entsprechenden Wert von Y zu sehen.
Und das ist eine ziemlich
deutliche Verbesserung gegenüber der Verwendung eines einzelnen Steuer-qubit.
Dies ist tatsächlich das Phasenschätzverfahren,
wenn wir uns für die Verwendung von zwei Steuer-qubits entscheiden.
Und was wir als nächstes tun werden, ist dieses
Verfahren auf natürliche Weise zu verallgemeinern, bei dem wir nicht bei
nur zwei Steuer-qubits aufhören
aber wir verwenden so viele
control qubits, wie wir möchten.
Und was wir sehen werden, ist, dass wir durch
die Verallgemeinerung des Verfahrens, durch das Hinzufügen weiterer control qubits, immer genauere
Näherungen von Theta erhalten können. Und das wird das allgemeine
Phasenschätzungsverfahren sein.
Um das Phasenschätzungsverfahren von
zwei control qubits auf beliebig viele zu
verallgemeinern, müssen wir verstehen,
wie die Quanten-Fourier-Transformation für andere Dimensionen definiert ist.
Und wir müssen auch besprechen, wie sie mit
einem quantum circuit implementiert werden kann.
Hier ist die Definition der
Quanten-Fourier-Transformation, wenn die Dimension eine
beliebige positive ganze Zahl N ist.
Hier betrachten wir diese Operation als eine Operation auf einem System, dessen klassische Zustände
von null bis N minus eins reichen.
Und hier wurde die Matrix, die
diese Operation beschreibt, mithilfe
der Dirac-Notation ausgedrückt.
Wir können sie auch anhand ihrer Wirkung
auf Standardbasiszustände beschreiben, um sie mit
dem zu verbinden, was wir bereits gesehen haben, wenn N gleich vier ist.
Hier sieht es also aus,
wenn N gleich eins ist, was kein besonders interessanter Fall ist.
Hier ist es für N gleich zwei, und du wirst bemerken, dass wir in diesem Fall eine Hadamard-Operation erhalten.
Hier ist die Quanten-Fourier-
Transformation für N gleich drei.
Für N gleich vier, was
wir bereits gesehen haben.
Und als letztes Beispiel sieht es so aus, wenn N gleich acht ist.
Genau wie zuvor
beim Fall N gleich vier sind dies die Matrizen, die wir mit der diskreten Fourier-Transformation verbinden
für jede der Dimensionen. Aber wir nennen sie
Quanten-Fourier-Transformation, wenn wir sie
als Quantenoperation betrachten möchten.
Manchmal übrigens ist der führende Faktor von eins durch die Quadratwurzel von N nicht enthalten, wenn wir die diskrete Fourier-
Transformation als Matrix betrachten,
aber wir brauchen diesen Faktor hier, um sicherzustellen, dass wir eine unitäre Matrix erhalten.
Manchmal gibt es auch ein Minuszeichen in jedem der Exponenten, aber nicht immer.
Es ist im Grunde nur eine persönliche Präferenz, die die grundlegende
Natur der Transformation nicht ändert.
Aber in jedem Fall werden wir die Quanten-Fourier-Transformation so definieren, wie sie hier auf dem Bildschirm geschrieben steht.
Es gibt eine sehr nützliche Kurzschreibweise,
die gebräuchlich ist, und wir werden sie
etwas später in der Lektion verwenden.
Und zwar definieren wir eine
komplexe Zahl Omega N, wie wir sie hier haben.
Insbesondere als e hoch zwei Pi i durch N, was auch mithilfe von Sinus und Kosinus geschrieben werden kann
wie wir es genau hier haben. Manchmal nennen wir diese
Zahl eine N-te Einheitswurzel, weil wir eins erhalten, wenn wir sie
zur Potenz N erheben.
Hier ist eine Abbildung, die einige Beispiele zeigt.
Omega eins ist gleich eins, Omega zwei ist gleich minus eins, und Omega vier ist gleich i.
Um Omega N im Allgemeinen zu erhalten, können wir uns vorstellen, den Einheitskreis in N gleich große Stücke aufzuteilen, wie eine Pizza, die von N Personen geteilt wird,
und Omega N befindet sich an der
Ecke des ersten Stücks, vorausgesetzt, dass die andere Ecke
dieses Stücks bei eins liegt.
Insbesondere werden die Stücke immer kleiner,
je größer N wird, und Omega N wird
immer näher an eins heranrücken.
Und wenn wir nun diese Notation verwenden, können wir die
Quanten-Fourier-Transformation etwas übersichtlicher ausdrücken.
Manchmal hilft diese Notation,
die Dinge einfach zu halten, wie wir
etwas später in der Lektion sehen werden.
Es gibt eine effiziente quantum circuit-
Implementierung der Quanten-Fourier-Transformation,
wenn N eine Zweierpotenz ist,
die wir uns jetzt ansehen werden. Obwohl wir die
Quanten-Fourier-Transformation für jede Dimension N definieren, werden wir sie nur
im Fall benötigen, dass N eine Zweierpotenz ist, um das
Phasenschätzungsverfahren zu verallgemeinern.
Die Implementierung wird
kontrollierte Phasen-gates verwenden, die so dargestellt werden, wie wir
es hier auf dem Bildschirm haben.
Sie sehen aus wie zwei
zusammen verbundene Steuerungen zusammen mit einer Zahl, die
in diesem Fall Alpha ist.
Und die Wirkung dieses gate wird durch die hier gezeigte Matrix beschrieben.
Das sind buchstäblich
kontrollierte Phasen-gates, was bedeutet, dass wir ein control qubit haben, das ein Phasen-gate steuert.
Phasen-gates haben wir schon ganz am Anfang in Lektion eins gesehen.
Aber speziell bei Phasen-gates spielt es eigentlich keine Rolle,
welches qubit das Steuer- und welches das Ziel-qubit ist.
Und das haben wir in Lektion zwei gesehen, für den speziellen Fall eines Z-gate.
Und jetzt, da wir diesen Begriff haben, können wir dazu übergehen, wie die
Quanten-Fourier-Transformation implementiert werden kann.
Die Implementierung ist rekursiver Natur, und vielleicht ist der einfachste Weg,
sie in einfachen Worten zu beschreiben, ein Beispiel zu geben, das
leicht verallgemeinert werden kann.
So können wir es machen,
wenn N gleich 32 ist.
Es gibt also fünf qubits.
Um es klar zu sagen: Wir ordnen die
Standardbasiszustände dieser fünf qubits den ganzen Zahlen zwischen null und 31 mithilfe der Binärschreibweise zu.
Als erstes führen wir die Quanten-Fourier-
Transformation für N gleich 16 auf allen qubits aus, außer dem
am wenigsten signifikanten qubit,
was die oberste ist. Und das ist der rekursive
Teil der Konstruktion.
Um diese Operation zu implementieren, müssen wir demselben
Muster folgen, aber mit einem Qubit weniger.
Und im Basisfall haben wir
nur ein einzelnes Qubit, für das die Quanten-Fourier-Transformation nur ein Hadamard gate ist.
Sobald wir die QFT auf alle qubits außer dem obersten anwenden, wenden wir eine Reihe von kontrollierten Phasengates mit den Phasen an, die
im Diagramm angegeben sind.
Dann wenden wir ein Hadamard
gate auf das oberste Qubit an und ordnen die qubits mithilfe einiger Swap-Gates ein wenig um.
Diese Swap-Gates haben den Effekt, die qubits zyklisch zu permutieren, was nötig ist, damit
die Konstruktion funktioniert.
Wir können genau dasselbe Muster für andere Wahlen von N
befolgen, vorausgesetzt sie sind Zweierpotenzen, wobei wir immer mit den
kontrollierten Phasengates beginnen,
wobei Alpha gleich Pi durch
zwei für das unterste Qubit ist und sich jedes Mal halbiert,
wenn man im Diagramm nach links geht,
um die nachfolgenden Phasen zu erhalten. Es ist überhaupt nicht offensichtlich,
dass diese Konstruktion funktioniert.
Und ich werde in diesem Video nicht erklären,
warum sie funktioniert.
Wenn du daran interessiert bist, die
Details dazu zu sehen, warum sie funktioniert, kannst du sie in den
schriftlichen Inhalten zur Lektion finden.
Ich möchte jedoch sagen, dass
das, was hier ausgenutzt wird, die grundlegende Struktur der
diskreten Fourier-Transformationen ist,
und es ist tatsächlich genau
dieselbe Struktur, die es der schnellen
Fourier-Transformation ermöglicht zu funktionieren.
Eine andere Weise, dies zu sagen, ist, dass wir, wenn wir uns die schnelle Fourier-Transformation ansehen, darüber nachdenken können
in Bezug auf quantum circuits.
Und das ist der circuit, den wir erhalten.
Wie viele gates brauchen wir also insgesamt für diese Implementierung?
Um das herauszufinden, sei SM die Anzahl der gates, die
wir brauchen, wenn wir M qubits haben.
Wenn M gleich eins ist, brauchen wir nur ein einzelnes gate, da die QFT in diesem Fall nur eine Hadamard-Operation ist.
Wenn M mindestens zwei ist, dann sind das
die gates, die wir brauchen.
Zunächst brauchen wir SM minus eins gates für die Quanten-Fourier-
Transformation auf M minus eins qubits, wie auch immer diese Zahl ist.
Wir brauchen auch M minus eins
kontrollierte Phasengates, M minus eins Swap-Gates,
und ein zusätzliches Hadamard gate.
Hier ist also ein Ausdruck
von SM in beiden Fällen, wenn M gleich eins ist und
wenn M mindestens zwei ist.
Dies ist ein Beispiel für das, was eine Rekurrenzrelation genannt wird, und
sie tauchen sehr häufig in der Analyse von Algorithmen auf.
Diese besondere
ist zufällig sehr einfach und hat einen sogenannten
geschlossenen Ausdruck, den wir durch Summieren erhalten können.
Genauer gesagt ist der Wert von SM die Summe der ersten M
aufeinanderfolgenden ungeraden ganzen Zahlen, was M Quadrat ergibt,
wie du entweder schon einmal begegnet bist oder vielleicht
irgendwann in deinem Leben einfach bemerkt hast.
Und es ist ziemlich einfach zu beweisen, dass diese Formel durch Induktion über M wahr ist,
falls du an einem formalen Beweis interessiert bist.
Das war es also. Wir können die
Quanten-Fourier-Transformation auf M qubits mit M Quadrat gates implementieren.
Nur noch ein paar sehr
kurze zusätzliche Anmerkungen.
Zunächst brauchen wir nicht wirklich
alle Swap-Gates, die ich beschrieben habe.
Es ist möglich, sie alle effektiv
ans Ende zu verschieben, solange wir anpassen, auf welche qubits die kontrollierten Phasengates
entsprechend wirken.
Und wenn wir das tun, brauchen wir insgesamt nur
M durch zwei Swap-Gates, abgerundet.
Wir haben immer noch quadratische Kosten, aber die Anzahl der gates kann auf diese Weise dennoch reduziert werden.
Und eine letzte Anmerkung ist, dass wir die Kosten sogar noch weiter senken können, wenn wir bereit sind, uns mit
einer ziemlich guten Näherung zu begnügen.
Wenn M beispielsweise groß wird, sind viele der kontrollierten Phasengates ziemlich nahe an
der Identitätsoperation,
und das Eliminieren derjenigen, die sehr nah dran sind, kann uns bei den gates erheblich einsparen, während wir uns immer noch eine
ziemlich gute Näherung sichern.
Es ist auch möglich, die Quanten-Fourier-Transformation
mit sehr flachen circuits zu approximieren, also solchen mit geringer Tiefe, falls das etwas ist,
was wir tun möchten.
Und jetzt, da wir wissen, was die
Quanten-Fourier-Transformation für verschiedene Dimensionen ist, sowie wie sie implementiert werden kann, wenn die Dimension eine Zweierpotenz ist,
können wir zum
Phasenschätzungsverfahren zurückkehren und sehen, wie es verallgemeinert werden kann, wenn wir eine beliebige
Anzahl M von Steuer-qubits verwenden.
So sieht das Verfahren als quantum circuit für
eine beliebige Wahl von M aus.
Wir haben M Steuer-qubits oben, von denen wir annehmen, dass sie alle
im Nullzustand initialisiert sind.
Wir wenden ein Hadamard
gate auf jedes von ihnen an, und dann wird jedes von ihnen als Steuer-Qubit verwendet, um eine Potenz der
unitären Operation U anzuwenden,
wobei wir die Anzahl der Anwendungen von U für jedes Steuer-Qubit verdoppeln.
Hier in diesem Diagramm habe ich das angezeigt, indem ich die Potenzen
von U in den Kästchen angegeben habe, anstatt das kontrollierte U-gate zu zeigen,
das so oft angewendet wird, als eine Möglichkeit, das
Diagramm klarer zu machen und Platz zu sparen, sodass
es auf den Bildschirm passt.
Nun ist das Erste, was wir über
dieses Verfahren beachten müssen, dass es sehr teuer werden könnte.
Insbesondere verdoppeln wir
die Anzahl der Anwendungen jeder U-Operation
für jedes Steuer-Qubit.
Und wenn wir das einfach dadurch tun, dass wir ein kontrolliertes U gate so oft iterieren, wie wir es brauchen,
werden wir einen riesigen circuit bekommen. Er wird exponentiell
groß in der Zahl M sein.
Das ist im Allgemeinen eine erhebliche Einschränkung, und insbesondere begrenzt es unsere Fähigkeit, präzise Näherungen
von Eigenwerten zu erhalten.
Im speziellen Fall der Faktorisierung jedoch, auf den wir gleich zu sprechen kommen, stellt sich heraus, dass wir sehr viel Glück haben und einen Trick anwenden können, der es uns erlaubt,
diesen exponentiellen Kostenanstieg zu vermeiden.
Aber im Allgemeinen wird das für beliebige
unitäre Operationen U nicht möglich sein und
wir werden einen hohen Preis zahlen,
wenn wir die
Anzahl der Steuer-qubits erhöhen.
Ich werde in diesem Video keine
detaillierte Analyse des circuits durchführen, sondern nur erwähnen, dass es einen recht einfachen
Ausdruck für den Zustand gibt,
kurz vor den Messungen, der hier auf dem Bildschirm zu sehen ist.
Aus diesem Zustand können wir einen Ausdruck für die Wahrscheinlichkeiten
der verschiedenen Ergebnisse ableiten, und er sieht so aus.
Und sobald wir diesen Ausdruck haben,
können wir darüber nachdenken, und dieser Ausdruck
ist wirklich alles, was wir brauchen, um weiterzumachen.
Wie gesagt, ich werde in diesem Video nicht auf
die Details eingehen, aber du kannst sie im
schriftlichen Inhalt der Lektion finden, und es stellt sich heraus, dass es
eigentlich gar nicht so kompliziert ist,
also schau es dir an, wenn du möchtest. Wenn wir die Analyse durchführen, stellen wir fest, dass die Situation
gar nicht so anders ist
als der Fall M gleich zwei, außer dass wir mehr Präzision erhalten.
Insbesondere können wir
zunächst über die Wahrscheinlichkeit nachdenken, die allerbeste oder eine der
zwei besten Näherungen zu erhalten,
die wir wie hier ausdrücken können.
Du kannst diesen Index von eins beim Absolutbetrag gerne ignorieren.
Das ist nur ein Symbol, das wir
verwenden können, um uns daran zu erinnern, dass wir über
Näherungen auf dem Kreis sprechen, bei dem wir theta gleich null
und theta gleich eins als identisch betrachten. Der Punkt hier ist, dass
wir über diejenige Wahl von Y nachdenken, die Y durch zwei hoch M
so nah wie möglich an theta bringt.
Und noch einmal, genau wie beim
Fall M gleich zwei, ist garantiert, dass wir dieses Ergebnis Y mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit von mindestens 40% erhalten.
Tatsächlich beträgt die Wahrscheinlichkeit
mindestens vier durch pi zum Quadrat, was etwas mehr als 40% ist.
10 ist keine schlechte
Näherung für pi zum Quadrat, wenn man es eilig hat.
Und das ist wirklich bemerkenswert. Wovon wir sprechen, ist, die allerbeste
Näherung an theta als Bruch Y durch zwei hoch M zu erhalten,
wobei Y eine ganze Zahl ist. Und wir erhalten die
allerbeste Näherung mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit von mehr als 40%.
Wir können auch über
schlechtere Näherungen nachdenken.
Stellen wir uns insbesondere vor,
dass Y nicht ganz so gut ist, und genauer gesagt nehmen wir an,
dass es eine bessere
Näherung an theta derselben Form gibt, die zwischen theta und Y durch zwei hoch M liegt,
was sich so ausdrücken lässt,
wie es auf dem Bildschirm steht.
In einem solchen Fall ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit, dieses Y zu erhalten, relativ gering, höchstens 25%.
Sie wird sogar noch niedriger sein, aber 25% erhalten wir aus
einer ziemlich einfachen Analyse, und das ist gut genug.
Als Beispiel: Hier ist der Plot, den wir erhalten, wenn wir drei Steuer-
qubits statt zwei verwenden.
Diesmal zeichne ich nur
die Wahrscheinlichkeiten für die Ergebnisse drei, vier und fünf ein, weil ich nicht möchte, dass die
Abbildung zu unübersichtlich wird.
Wenn theta zum Beispiel gleich
ein halb ist, ist garantiert, dass wir das Ergebnis vier erhalten.
Und so nehmen wir unsere
Näherung als vier Achtel oder ein halb an, weil zwei
hoch drei gleich acht ist.
Und in diesem Fall liegen wir genau richtig. Und solange theta näher an ein halb als an, sagen wir, drei
Achtel ist,
erhalten wir das Ergebnis vier mit einer höheren
Wahrscheinlichkeit als das Ergebnis drei.
Und mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit,
die wieder größer als 40% ist.
Hier ist der Plot, wenn M gleich vier ist. Und die Kurven sehen
eigentlich ziemlich identisch aus, außer dass wir jetzt um einen Faktor zwei
hineingezoomt haben.
Jetzt umfassen die eingezeichneten Ergebnisse sieben, acht und neun, und wir nehmen die Näherung als eine dieser Zahlen
geteilt durch 16 statt acht.
Und ich zeige noch einen weiteren Plot, bei dem wir auf M gleich fünf erhöhen.
Und wieder werden wir
um einen Faktor zwei hineinzoomen.
Und hier ist er. Noch einmal sehen die Kurven
ziemlich identisch aus, aber wir verdoppeln
unsere Präzision effektiv.
Und wie zuvor erhalten wir die allerbeste Näherung an theta mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit von mehr als 40%.
Das ist ziemlich erstaunlich. Aber wenn 40% als Maß für die Konfidenz nicht gut genug ist,
können wir das Verfahren eine kleine Anzahl von Malen ausführen und
den Modus der Ergebnisse nehmen, also denjenigen, der
am häufigsten vorkommt.
Und wenn wir das tun, werden wir mit sehr hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit eine sehr gute Näherung an theta erhalten.
Denk übrigens daran, dass jedes Mal, wenn wir das
Phasenschätzungsverfahren ausführen, der Eigenvektor
unverändert herauskommt.
Das Verfahren steht uns also zur Verfügung, um es
mehrfach auf diese Weise auszuführen.
Kurz gesagt, wir sammeln
Statistiken über Theta, und der Punkt ist, dass wir dadurch eine sehr präzise
Annäherung an Theta erhalten können
mit sehr hoher Konfidenz, und wir brauchen dafür nicht viele Iterationen des Verfahrens.
Und so funktioniert das
Phasenschätzungsverfahren.
Im letzten Teil der Lektion wenden wir die Technik
der Phasenschätzung auf das ganzzahlige Faktorisierungsproblem an.
Wie ich am Anfang des Videos erwähnt habe, funktioniert das so, dass wir ein Zwischenproblem betrachten, das als Ordnungsfindungsproblem bekannt ist.
Wir werden sehen, wie wir das
Ordnungsfindungsproblem mithilfe der Phasenschätzung lösen können, und dann werden wir kurz besprechen, wie die Lösung des Ordnungsfindungsproblems
es uns ermöglicht, ganze Zahlen effizient zu faktorisieren.
Der zweite Teil ist vollständig klassisch, und ich werde in diesem Video nur die
Grundidee zusammenfassen.
Aber beginnen wir mit dem
Ordnungsfindungsproblem.
Zunächst wollen wir uns eine
praktische Notation zurechtlegen.
Für jede positive ganze Zahl N definieren wir ZN als die ganzen Zahlen
von null bis N minus eins.
So hat zum Beispiel Z eins ein
einziges Element, nämlich null, Z zwei hat die Elemente null und eins,
Z drei hat die Elemente null,
eins und zwei, und so weiter.
ZN ist also eine Menge.
Wir können es aber auch als
mehr als eine Menge betrachten. Wir können arithmetische Operationen wie Addition und Multiplikation auf ZN betrachten
indem wir sie modular N definieren.
Nehmen wir zum Beispiel an,
N ist gleich sieben.
Wir haben, dass drei und fünf
Elemente von Z sieben sind, und wenn wir sie miteinander multiplizieren, erhalten wir 15
was nach der Division durch sieben
einen Rest von eins lässt.
Manchmal drücken wir das aus, indem wir schreiben, dass drei mal fünf
kongruent zu eins modulo sieben ist, wie hier geschrieben.
Wir können aber auch einfach schreiben, dass drei mal fünf gleich eins ist.
Natürlich ist drei mal fünf
normalerweise nicht gleich eins, sondern gleich 15.
Aber wenn klar ist, dass
wir in Z sieben arbeiten, das heißt, dass die Multiplikation
modular sieben definiert ist,
können wir einfach schreiben, dass
drei mal fünf gleich eins ist.
Nun werden unter den Elementen
von ZN für jedes positive N manche von ihnen einen
ggT gleich eins mit N haben
und manche nicht. Und die Elemente, die einen ggT gleich eins mit N haben, sind besonders.
Und wir schreiben ZN Stern, um auf die Menge genau dieser Elemente zu verweisen.
So ist hier zum Beispiel Z 21 Stern.
Von den Elementen von Z 21, von denen es natürlich 21 gibt, haben 12 von ihnen einen ggT gleich eins
mit 21 und der Rest nicht.
Insbesondere überspringen wir jedes Mal, wenn wir ein Element von Z 21 haben, das durch
drei oder sieben teilbar ist, dieses.
Es gibt verschiedene Gründe,
warum diese Menge besonders ist, und einer der Gründe ist, dass wenn wir ein Element von ZN Stern haben,
und wir die positiven ganzzahligen
Potenzen dieser Zahl betrachten, werden wir immer irgendwann
die Zahl eins erreichen,
wobei wir wie zuvor über Multiplikation modular N sprechen.
Die kleinste positive ganzzahlige Potenz, die uns eins ergibt, wird als
Ordnung dieses Elements bezeichnet.
Betrachten wir zum Beispiel das Element A gleich vier in Z 21 Stern.
Vier mal vier ist 16, was nicht gleich eins modulo 21 ist, aber wenn wir noch einmal mit vier multiplizieren,
erhalten wir 64, und 64 modulo
21 ist gleich eins.
Die Ordnung von vier modulo 21 ist also drei.
Das Erreichen von eins auf diese Weise passiert immer für alle Elemente von ZN Stern.
Und übrigens passiert es niemals
für Elemente von ZN, die nicht in ZN Stern sind.
Daher ist ein ggT gleich eins
mit N wie hier sowohl notwendig als auch
hinreichend dafür, dass das passiert.
Und um das Beispiel N gleich 21 abzuschließen, hier sind die kleinsten
positiven ganzzahligen Potenzen, für die das für
jedes Element von Z 21 Stern funktioniert,
und sie können einzeln überprüft werden.
Und jetzt können wir das
Ordnungsfindungsproblem formulieren, das einfach darin besteht, die Ordnung für ein gegebenes Element in ZN Stern zu finden.
Genauer gesagt ist die Eingabe
zwei positive ganze Zahlen A und N, für die der ggT gleich eins ist,
und die Ausgabe ist die
kleinste positive ganze Zahl R, sodass A hoch R
kongruent zu eins modulo N ist,
oder gleichwertig die
kleinste positive ganze Zahl R, für die A hoch R gleich eins ist.
Vorausgesetzt, wir rechnen in ZN.
Es wird angenommen, dass dies ein
rechnerisch schwieriges Problem ist, kein effizienter klassischer Algorithmus
ist zur Lösung bekannt.
Und wie wir besprechen werden, ist das Problem mindestens so schwer wie
die ganzzahlige Faktorisierung, in dem Sinne, dass wenn wir einen Algorithmus zur Lösung der Ordnungsfindung haben,
wir in der Lage wären, diesen Algorithmus zu verwenden, um das ganzzahlige
Faktorisierungsproblem effizient zu lösen.
Tatsächlich gilt das auch umgekehrt, das heißt, wenn du zufällig einen Algorithmus zum Faktorisieren hast, kannst du ihn verwenden, um
das Ordnungsbestimmungsproblem zu lösen.
Die beiden Probleme sind
in gewissem Sinne gleichwertig in Bezug auf ihre
Berechnungskomplexität.
Jetzt werden wir sehen, wie wir
das Ordnungsbestimmungsproblem auf einem Quantencomputer
mithilfe von Phasenschätzung lösen können.
Um eine Verbindung zwischen den Problemen herzustellen, stellen wir uns vor, dass wir ein System haben, dessen klassische Zustandsmenge AN ist.
Für jede Wahl eines Elements A in ZN Stern definieren wir eine Operation
MA wie wir sie hier haben.
Was MA in Worten tut, ist, mit A zu multiplizieren, und hier ist die Multiplikation modular N.
Und für den Rest dieser Lektion solltest du immer daran denken,
dass Ausdrücke innerhalb von Kets modular N berechnet werden,
damit wir die Dinge einfach halten können und nicht immer wieder
mod N schreiben müssen.
Dies ist eine unitäre Operation, aber das gilt nur,
weil A in ZN Stern ist.
Wenn der GCD von A und N nicht eins ist, wird diese Operation nicht unitär sein.
Hier ist ein Beispiel. Wenn N gleich 15 und A gleich zwei ist, was in Z 15 Stern liegt, dann
ist das die Wirkung von M zwei.
Und wenn du dieses
Beispiel einen Moment lang betrachtest, wirst du sehen, dass die Elemente von ZN durch diese Wirkung einfach permutiert werden.
Es ist also sowohl deterministisch als auch unitär, was bedeutet, dass MA als Matrix eine Permutationsmatrix ist.
Und hier ist die Hauptidee. Die Eigenwerte von MA sind
sehr eng verbunden
mit der Ordnung von A. Und indem wir Phasenschätzung verwenden, um diese
Eigenwerte hinreichend genau anzunähern,
können wir die Ordnung von A bestimmen. Was genau sind also die Eigenvektoren und die Eigenwerte von MA?
Nun, wir brauchen nicht alle davon, wir brauchen nur einige von ihnen.
Fangen wir mit einem einfachen Beispiel an.
Hier ist ein Eigenvektor von MA, wir haben ihn Psi Null genannt, und er ist gegeben durch die
Summe von Ket eins, Ket a,
Ket A zum Quadrat, und so weiter bis zu Ket A hoch R minus eins, alles dividiert durch die Quadratwurzel von R,
um ihn zu einem Einheitsvektor zu machen. Hier ist R die Ordnung von A.
Und ich reserviere den
Buchstaben R für die Ordnung von A für den Rest der Lektion.
Immer wenn du R siehst, ist das die Ordnung von A für
welches A auch immer wir gerade besprechen.
Der Eigenwert, der
diesem Eigenvektor zugeordnet ist, ist eins.
Und das können wir überprüfen, indem wir
MA auf diesen Vektor anwenden und sehen, was wir erhalten.
MA multipliziert mit A, also
müssen wir jeden der Exponenten um eins erhöhen, und das ist es, was wir erhalten.
Aber die Ordnung von A ist R, also ist A hoch R gleich eins.
Und wir können diese Substitution vornehmen.
Aber das ist derselbe Vektor,
mit dem wir angefangen haben. Wir haben nur die Kets umgestellt, aber da wir die Summe nehmen,
ändert das nichts.
Also ist MA mal Psi Null gleich Psi Null.
Es ist also ein Eigenvektor von
MA mit Eigenwert eins.
Das ist ein sehr einfaches
Beispiel für einen Eigenvektor, und um weitere zu identifizieren, erinnern wir uns an die gleiche Notation, die wir früher in der Lektion hatten.
Omega R ist die komplexe
Zahl auf dem Einheitskreis, die wir erhalten, indem wir E hoch zwei mal Pi mal I nehmen
dividiert durch R. Zuletzt hatten wir ein N anstatt eines R, aber es funktioniert genauso
für R anstelle von N.
Wir brauchen diese Zahl, weil
sie in den anderen Eigenvektoren
von MA auftauchen wird, die wir identifizieren werden.
Und nachdem wir diese Notation in Erinnerung gerufen haben, können wir feststellen, dass dieser
Vektor namens Psi eins ebenfalls ein Eigenvektor von MA ist.
Er ähnelt Psi Null, wir haben genau die gleichen Kets und summieren sie auf und
dividieren durch die Quadratwurzel von R.
Aber dieses Mal haben wir verschiedene Phasen, die jeden der Kets multiplizieren.
Omega R hoch negativ eins für A, Omega R hoch negativ zwei für A zum Quadrat, und so weiter bis zu Omega R hoch
negativ R minus eins
für A hoch R minus eins. Also ist die Potenz von Omega R immer negativ eins mal welche Potenz von A
auch immer innerhalb des Kets steht.
Ich werde das nicht im Detail durchgehen, aber es ist auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt, falls du das Video erneut anschauen und pausieren möchtest.
Aber wenn wir die Multiplikation durchführen und wieder vereinfachen, indem wir die Tatsache nutzen, dass A hoch R gleich eins ist,
sowie die sehr wichtige Tatsache, dass Omega hoch R gleich eins ist, werden wir feststellen, dass wir
wieder einen Eigenvektor von MA haben.
Wenn wir die Vereinfachung durchführen, müssen wir diesmal einen Faktor von Omega R herausziehen, um zu sehen, dass wir tatsächlich einen Eigenvektor haben,
und dieser Wert von Omega R stellt den Eigenwert dar, der diesem Eigenvektor zugeordnet ist.
Das ist also ein zweites Eigenvektor-
Eigenwert-Paar von NA.
Wir können weitere Eigenvektoren mit genau demselben Reasoning identifizieren, und tatsächlich, wenn wir einfach Omega R
durch Omega R hoch J für jedes J zwischen null und R minus eins ersetzen, erhalten wir immer einen Eigenvektor,
und der zugehörige Eigenwert wird Omega R hoch J sein.
Das schließt tatsächlich
Psi Null und Psi eins ein, die wir bereits gesehen haben,
sowie R minus zwei weitere Eigenvektor-Eigenwert-Paare.
Sie funktionieren alle grundsätzlich auf dieselbe Weise, und um sie zu überprüfen, müssen wir nur wissen, dass A hoch R gleich eins ist,
sowie Omega R hoch
R gleich eins.
Es gibt andere Eigenvektoren von MA, wie zum Beispiel cat zero, aber die werden uns nicht nützlich sein und wir müssen uns keine Gedanken darüber machen.
Wir müssen uns nur um psi zero bis psi R minus eins kümmern.
Lass uns kurz auf psi eins eingehen, nur um zu verstehen, warum uns diese Eigenvektoren interessieren
und was sie uns
über die Ordnung R verraten können, die wir ja bestimmen möchten.
Angenommen, wir haben
den Eigenvektor psi eins gegeben, können wir versuchen,
R auf folgende Weise zu bestimmen.
Zuerst führen wir die Phasenschätzung
auf diesem Eigenvektor durch, indem wir einen quantum circuit verwenden, der
die Operation MA implementiert.
Was wir erhalten, ist eine Näherung für theta, was in diesem Fall eins durch R ist.
Und zweitens: Da wir nach R suchen und wir eine
Näherung für eins durch R haben, liegt es nahe,
den Kehrwert zu berechnen
und ihn auf die
nächste ganze Zahl zu runden. Wir müssen so runden,
weil R eine ganze Zahl sein muss.
Aber wir haben eins durch R nicht exakt, sondern nur eine Näherung dafür.
Wenn die Näherung aber gut genug ist, erhalten wir R beim Runden,
was wir ja suchen.
Und jetzt stellt sich die Frage, wie viel Genauigkeit wir benötigen, um R durch Berechnung des Kehrwerts und Runden korrekt zu bestimmen.
Oder anders gesagt, wie genau muss unsere
Näherung sein, damit das alles funktioniert?
Nun, es stellt sich heraus, dass wir eine ziemlich genaue Näherung benötigen.
Zum Beispiel können wir es uns
nicht leisten, eins durch R mit eins durch R plus eins oder eins durch R minus eins zu verwechseln.
Diese beiden Brüche, eins durch R plus eins und
eins durch R minus eins, liegen bei großem R ziemlich nah an eins
durch R.
Aber obwohl wir eine
ziemlich genaue Näherung benötigen, brauchen wir keine lächerlich
genaue Näherung, und es lässt sich zeigen, dass,
wenn unsere Näherung
die Ungleichung erfüllt, die
wir hier auf dem Bildschirm sehen, das Runden
das richtige Ergebnis liefert.
Ich werde das in diesem Video nicht beweisen, aber es wird in den schriftlichen
Materialien zur Lektion gezeigt, falls du an den Details interessiert bist.
Und wenn das die Genauigkeit ist,
die wir anstreben, dann reicht es aus, eine
bestimmte Anzahl von Steuer-qubits im Phasenschätzverfahren zu verwenden
die gleich zwei mal
der Länge von N plus eins ist.
Wobei die Länge von N, wie wir in den vorherigen Lektionen gesehen haben, die Anzahl der Bits ist, die wir benötigen, um N binär darzustellen.
Übrigens, wenn wir uns damit begnügen,
die beste Näherung mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit von mindestens 40 % zu erhalten, und wir nicht versuchen,
unser Vertrauen zu erhöhen,
wie ich es vorhin beschrieben habe, brauchen wir das plus eins eigentlich nicht.
Aber in jedem Fall gilt, dass die Anzahl
der Steuer-qubits, die wir benötigen, linear in der Länge von N
als Binärstring ist.
Wir haben gesehen, dass wir, wenn wir
den Eigenvektor psi eins haben, die Phasenschätzung verwenden können, um R zu finden, vorausgesetzt wir nutzen ausreichend Genauigkeit.
Leider ist es nicht so einfach, diesen Eigenvektor in die Hände zu bekommen.
Lass uns also eine andere Frage stellen.
Angenommen, wir haben nicht psi eins, sondern psi
für eine zufällige Wahl von J.
Können wir trotzdem herausfinden, was R ist? Oder können wir zumindest
etwas über R herausfinden?
Und die Antwort ist ja, wir können etwas
über R herausfinden, zumindest im Durchschnitt.
Was wir tun können, ist zu versuchen,
J durch R mit einer sehr ähnlichen Methode zu bestimmen,
wie der, die wir gerade gesehen haben,
aber mit einem wesentlichen Unterschied.
Zuerst machen wir genau
dasselbe wie zuvor, nämlich das Phasenschätzverfahren
auf dem Eigenvektor psi J auszuführen.
Und was wir erhalten, ist eine
Näherung für J durch R, im Gegensatz zu eins durch R,
was wir vorher hatten.
Aber jetzt haben wir ein kleines Problem, denn das Berechnen des
Kehrwerts ergibt nicht R, sondern R durch J.
Und übrigens, wir gehen
nicht davon aus, dass wir wissen, was J ist – wir haben einfach psi J für ein zufälliges J gegeben,
und wir werden nicht gesagt, was J ist. Was können wir also tun?
Nun, es stellt sich heraus, dass es einen bekannten
klassischen Algorithmus gibt, der uns helfen kann, nämlich den
Kettenbruchalgorithmus.
Und was dieser Algorithmus tun kann, ist unsere Näherung
Y durch zwei hoch M zu nehmen und uns zu sagen, welcher Bruch U durch V,
in gekürzter Form geschrieben, und wobei U und V beide
ganze Zahlen kleiner als N sind, unserer Näherung am nächsten liegt.
Es ist ein wirklich faszinierender Algorithmus, und wenn du dich dafür interessierst, solltest du ihn dir unbedingt ansehen.
Er ist tatsächlich sehr eng mit dem Euklidischen Algorithmus zur
Berechnung von GCDs verwandt.
Aber ich werde in diesem Video
nicht weiter darauf eingehen.
Der Kern davon ist, dass wir, wenn wir eine gute
Näherung für einen Bruch haben, bei dem Zähler und
Nenner nicht zu groß sind,
der Algorithmus den Bruch wiederherstellen kann, und genau das machen wir hier.
Und nun stehen wir vor genau
der gleichen Frage wie zuvor, nämlich wie viel Genauigkeit wir benötigen.
Und es stellt sich heraus, dass
genau dieselbe Schranke wie zuvor auch in diesem Fall gilt.
Und so funktioniert die Wahl von M auf genau
die gleiche Weise wie zuvor auch hier.
Das wird uns nicht unbedingt
R verraten.
Was wir herausfinden, wenn wir
genügend Präzision verwenden, ist J über R, aber das wird ein
vollständig gekürzter Bruch sein.
Wir könnten also Pech haben in dem Sinne, dass diese zufällige Wahl von J gemeinsame Faktoren mit R haben könnte,
und diese werden uns verborgen bleiben. Im schlimmsten Fall könnten wir zum Beispiel J gleich null bekommen und würden absolut nichts erfahren.
Aber das ist buchstäblich der einzige
Fall, in dem wir nichts erfahren.
Im Allgemeinen erhalten wir zumindest
einen nicht-trivialen Faktor von R, und wenn wir in der Lage sind, Zufallsstichproben zu ziehen
und psi J für verschiedene Wahlen von J zu erhalten, können wir R tatsächlich mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit wiederherstellen, indem wir das kleinste gemeinsame Vielfache berechnen
aller Nenner,
die wir beobachten. Und dafür braucht man tatsächlich
gar nicht viele Stichproben.
Unterm Strich gilt: Manche Wahlen von J werden Faktoren von R verbergen, aber zufällige Wahlen von J
werden die Faktoren von R
nicht lange verbergen können.
Das ist also die Idee. Es bleibt noch die Implementierung zu betrachten und insbesondere herauszufinden,
wie viel sie kostet.
Das Wesentliche der Idee, die Ordnung eines
gegebenen Elements A in ZN Stern zu berechnen, besteht darin, das Phasenabschätzungsverfahren anzuwenden
auf die Operation MA.
Lass uns herausfinden, was
die Kosten dafür sind, als Funktion der Länge von N (Großbuchstabe), die ich mit kleinem n bezeichne.
Hier ist ein circuit für die Phasenabschätzung. Wir brauchen kleine n qubits im unteren Teil des circuit
zur binären Darstellung von Elementen aus ZN. Wir haben also N Kontroll-qubits oben und kleine n qubits unten,
was praktisch ist, weil das mit den Namen übereinstimmt, die wir
früher in der Lektion verwendet haben.
Um die
Anzahl der gates zu zählen, die wir für den gesamten circuit benötigen, konzentrieren wir uns zunächst auf die Kosten der gesteuerten unitären Operationen.
Wenn wir die Techniken
aus der vorherigen Lektion, Lektion sechs, verwenden, können wir MA mit O von kleinem n zum Quadrat gates implementieren
unter Verwendung effizienter klassischer Algorithmen für Arithmetik modulo N.
Ich überspringe die Details in diesem Video, aber wie bei einigen anderen
Dingen, über die ich gesprochen habe, kannst du mehr darüber im schriftlichen Material zur Lektion lesen.
Es reicht aber nicht aus,
nur MA zu implementieren.
Wir müssen auch MA zum Quadrat, MA zur vierten Potenz, zur
achten Potenz und so weiter implementieren
bis hin zu MA zu einer Potenz, die exponentiell in M ist.
Und wir wissen, dass wir M linear in kleinem n wählen müssen,
um genügend Präzision zu erhalten.
Das ist ein großes Problem,
das ich früher schon angesprochen habe.
Wenn wir Potenzen
von MA durch einfaches Iterieren von MA implementieren würden, gäbe es Probleme, weil all diese Iterationen von MA
exponentielle Kosten verursachen würden.
Glücklicherweise können wir einen Trick anwenden, um diesen Kostenexplosion zu vermeiden.
Was wir tun können, ist Folgendes, für jede Potenz K, die wir benötigen.
Zunächst berechnen wir A hoch
K, modulo N.
Das ist das modulare Exponentierungsproblem, das ich in Lektion sechs erwähnt habe.
Und es kann effizient gelöst werden. Und das ist etwas, das wir mit einem klassischen Computer erledigen können.
Diese Berechnung muss
überhaupt nicht von einem quantum circuit durchgeführt werden.
Lass uns also B als das Ergebnis bezeichnen.
B ist also ein Element von ZN Stern.
Und zweitens verwenden wir anstelle von MA hoch K einfach einen circuit für MB.
Und das war's. B ist nur irgendein Element von ZN Stern, also betragen die Kosten zur Implementierung von MB
O von kleinem n zum Quadrat.
Kurz gesagt: Wir potenzieren in ZN, anstatt
einen quantum circuit zu potenzieren.
Aber die eigentliche Operation, die wir erhalten, ist in beiden Fällen dieselbe. Es ist einfach die Multiplikation mit A, K Mal.
Das ist gewissermaßen ein Wunder. Und wir wären nicht in der Lage,
das Ordnungsfindungsproblem zu lösen oder ganze Zahlen effizient zu faktorisieren
mit einem Quantencomputer,
wenn das nicht so wäre.
Und jetzt, da wir wissen, dass jede der gesteuerten
unitären Operationen, einschließlich der Potenzen, implementiert werden kann
mit Kosten von O von n zum Quadrat, können wir die Gesamtzahl
der benötigten gates zählen.
Wir haben N Hadamard gates, und weil M gleich
O von kleinem n ist, betragen die Kosten O von kleinem n.
Wir haben M gesteuerte unitäre Operationen, die jeweils Kosten von O von N zum Quadrat haben.
Die Gesamtkosten hier betragen
also O von N hoch drei.
Und schließlich hat die Quanten-Fourier-Transformation Kosten von O von n zum Quadrat.
Die Gesamtkosten betragen also O von N hoch drei.
Insbesondere sehen wir, dass selbst mit unserem
modularen Exponentierungstrick die Kosten der gesteuerten
unitären Operationen dominieren.
Dennoch sind die Kosten
polynomial in kleinem n.
Es gibt auch einige klassische
Berechnungen, die erforderlich sind, wie das Berechnen der modularen Exponentiierungen und das Ausführen des Kettenbruchalgorithmus,
aber diese Berechnungen
haben ebenfalls polynomiale Kosten. Und tatsächlich können sie auch mit O von N hoch drei Operationen durchgeführt werden.
Es gibt nur noch ein verbleibendes Problem, und zwar dass wir einen dieser Eigenvektoren in die Hände bekommen müssen.
Wie können wir das machen?
Die Lösung ist eigentlich ganz einfach. Wir führen den circuit
nicht auf einem Eigenvektor aus.
Wir führen ihn einfach auf dem Zustand eins aus, also der binären
Codierung der Zahl eins, die wir uns
als Element von ZN vorstellen.
Also nehmen wir diese
Ersetzung im Diagramm vor.
Der Grund, warum das funktioniert, liegt in dieser Gleichung hier.
Der Zustand ket eins ist tatsächlich eine gleichmäßige Superposition der R Eigenvektoren,
über die wir gesprochen haben.
Das ist nicht sofort offensichtlich, aber wenn du die
Summe berechnest, solltest du ket eins erhalten.
Und wenn wir den circuit auf diesen Zustand anwenden, ist die Ausgabe, die wir erhalten,
genau dieselbe, als hätten wir J zufällig gewählt
und das Verfahren auf
dem Eigenvektor psi J ausgeführt.
Auch das ist nicht offensichtlich, aber eine Analyse zeigt, dass es stimmt.
Und das war es schließlich. Wir haben einen effizienten Quanten-
algorithmus zur Ordnungsbestimmung.
Es gibt noch einen sehr kurzen Teil
der Lektion, der die Beziehung zwischen ganzzahliger Faktorisierung
und Ordnungsbestimmung betrifft.
Ich habe erwähnt, dass wir, wenn wir das Ordnungsbestimmungsproblem effizient lösen können,
auch ganze Zahlen effizient faktorisieren können.
Und ich möchte dir kurz die Hauptidee erläutern, wie das funktioniert.
Das ist vollständig klassisch. Dieser Teil hat eigentlich nichts
mit quantum computing zu tun.
Hier ist eine Methode, um
einen nicht-trivialen Faktor einer gegebenen positiven ganzen Zahl N zu finden.
Übrigens funktioniert diese Methode nur, wenn N eine ungerade Zahl ist und keine Primzahl
ist, die auf eine Potenz erhoben wurde.
Diese zwei Fälle, wenn N
gerade oder eine Primzahlpotenz ist, können separat behandelt werden.
Es gibt effiziente klassische Methoden sowohl zum Erkennen als auch
zur Behandlung dieser beiden Fälle.
Diese Methode ist probabilistisch. Sie könnte scheitern, aber die
Wahrscheinlichkeit des Scheiterns beträgt höchstens die Hälfte,
und wir können sie einfach
mehrmals unabhängig voneinander ausführen, um die Wahrscheinlichkeit
eines Fehlers exponentiell schnell zu reduzieren.
Zunächst wählen wir A zwischen
zwei und N minus eins gleichmäßig zufällig.
Dann berechnen wir den GCD von A und N.
Und wenn der GCD
größer als eins ist, hatten wir einfach unglaubliches Glück.
Der GCD ist dann ein Faktor von N, und wir können ihn einfach ausgeben und aufhören.
Andernfalls läuft der Algorithmus weiter, und wir wissen jetzt, dass A in ZN stern ist.
Und jetzt berechnen wir die Ordnung von A, wofür wir einen Quantencomputer benötigen.
Oder vielleicht haben wir eine andere
Möglichkeit, die Ordnung zu berechnen. Der Algorithmus ist eigentlich
egal, woher sie kommt, aber die einzige Möglichkeit, die wir kennen,
um das effizient zu tun,
ist mit einem Quantencomputer.
Wenn die Ordnung von R gerade ist, berechnen wir den GCD von
A hoch R durch zwei minus eins mit N.
Und wenn dieser GCD größer als eins ist, haben wir wieder einen Faktor von N, also geben wir ihn aus und hören auf.
Andernfalls ist der Algorithmus gescheitert. In diesem Fall können wir
zum Anfang zurückgehen und ein anderes A wählen
und auf ein besseres
Ergebnis beim nächsten Mal hoffen.
Und das war es. Übrigens, sobald wir
einen Faktor von N gefunden haben, können wir rekursiv sowohl auf diesen Faktor
als auch durch diesen Faktor dividieren, bis wir eine Primfaktorzerlegung von N haben.
Warum sollte das also funktionieren?
Es gibt zwei Hauptpunkte. Der erste ist, dass weil A hoch R kongruent zu eins modulo N ist,
gilt, dass N teilt A
hoch R minus eins.
Diese zwei Aussagen
sind tatsächlich äquivalent. Das ist die Definition von mod N, die du in Zahlentheoriebüchern findest.
Zweitens: Wenn R gerade ist, dann ist diese Gleichung, die
wir hier haben, wahr.
Das ist die bekannte Formel
für eine Differenz von Quadraten.
Tatsächlich gilt die Gleichung für alle R, aber wir brauchen R durch zwei als
ganze Zahl in Schritt vier.
Und wenn wir die beiden Fakten zusammenfügen, sehen wir, dass jeder Primfaktor von N einen der beiden
Ausdrücke in Klammern teilen muss,
denn das ist die einzige Möglichkeit,
wie N das Produkt teilen kann.
Nun könnte es sein, dass jeder
einzelne Primfaktor von N den ersten
Ausdruck in Klammern teilt und nicht den zweiten, aber für unser zufälliges A
ist das nicht sehr wahrscheinlich. Und wenn wir
den GCD in Schritt vier berechnen, erhalten wir wahrscheinlich das Produkt
einiger der Primfaktoren
von N, aber nicht aller.
Eine sorgfältige Analyse
erfordert etwas Zahlentheorie, aber das ist recht grundlegende Zahlentheorie.
Also, wenn du Zahlentheorie
interessant findest und mehr darüber lernen möchtest, versuche diese Analyse durchzuarbeiten.
Solche Dinge durchzuarbeiten ist ein ausgezeichneter Weg, mehr zu lernen, aber das überlasse ich dir.
Und das ist das Ende der Lektion. In dieser Lektion haben wir
das Phasenschätzungsproblem behandelt, wie wir es effizient
auf einem Quantencomputer lösen können,
und wie wir die Lösung anwenden können, um einen polynomiellen
Quantenalgorithmus für die ganzzahlige Faktorisierung zu erhalten.
Ich hoffe, du bist bei der nächsten Lektion dabei, die Grovers
Quanten-Suchalgorithmus behandelt.
Auf Wiedersehen bis dahin.